nouvel invité pour la série dans son
corps aujourd'hui je reçois émis make-up
pro et vient nous parler de sa
particularité physique à elle c'est à
dire bah non je vais pas vous spoiler
en même temps vous avez dû voir le titre
de la vidéo ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
amy et maquilleuse professionnelle
chroniqueuse beauté et youtube deux
salué mais ça lui vient alors quelle est
ta particularités physiques à toi alors
ma particularité physique c'est que j'ai
des jambes qui s'appelle enfin jamais
d'ailleurs des jambes en forme de
poteaux et plus précisément c'est que
j'ai un ipod m d'accord le lib dems est
un trouble qui touche les tissus adipeux
c'est à dire les graisses et leur
répartition dans le corps la graisse
s'accumule au niveau des jambes qui
deviennent gonflé et douloureuse mais ça
ne touche pas du tout le reste du corps
que tu te souviens le le jour où tu t'es
rendu compte que ça va cette
particularité a oui tout à fait en fait
c'est à l'adolescence je venais d'avoir
mes premières règles cela truc très très
glamour pour une visite vous votez non
voilà en fait pas en un an j'ai pris dix
kilos d'un coup et en fait mes jambes se
sont complètement transformé j'avais
plus du tout forme ça faisait tout droit
donc c'était assez impressionnant et
j'avais une 10 morphy entre l'eau de mon
corps et le bas de mon corps donc
j'avais un mot tout mince tout bien
tracée et 1 bat vraiment pas dire très
prépondérante a su tout de suite ce que
c'était ou est ce que tu te demandes ce
qui t'arrive à tort alors non j'ai pas
se douter que j'ai su ce que j'avais il
ya un an maintenant un peu plus d'un an
non j'ai été voir pas mal de mes seins
j'essayais de comprendre parce qu'au
delà de cet aspect physique que je
décris j'avais vraiment mal
j'avais des bleus qui apparaît c'est
sans que je comprenne et les médecins
bizet banamba grande c'est aussi ta
morphologie c'est comme ça c'est la vie
donc c'était difficile pour moi parce
que je savais pas comment m'habiller
c'est une souffrance j'avais honte tu
vas pour aller à la plage je mettais des
joggings ont jeté à l'eau et on disait
ben alors sur ses remparts jogging non
non j'ai chaud en fait c'était une
souffrance psychologique quoi c'est
vraiment bizarre c'est pour une fille
c'est un gars aussi je suppose mais en
fait on se sent anormale doit on n'a pas
des gens comme le jour où on pas où on a
bien non et on t'a dit que c'était une
maladie est ce que tu te souviens parce
que s'attache à ce que ça t'a fait ah
ouais je me souviens très bien en fait
je rentrais d'une soirée et savoir que
depuis maintenant 9 ans puis sur youtube
j'ai toujours fait attention à pas trop
axé mes jambes ou sinon je les accepte
une façon tu vois je des plantes plutôt
qui mettait en avant et c'est j'ai reçus
en fait un mail d'une fille qui me suit
qui s'appelle pauline et qui m'a dit
écoute est ce que ça t'a tel ou tel
comment dire si une offre est simple de
tels ou tels symptômes et je lui dis oui
et lamar envoyer un message en disant
ton hypothèse est la sensation c'est que
j'ai au début ça m'a fait mal au coeur
parce que je me suis dit mince
en fait elle a vu mes jambes que je
cachais bien tout le temps et finalement
j'ai un problème et en même temps j'ai
une sensation de joie parce que pour la
première fois on me disait tu es malade
tu as une maladie donc c'était une
balance vidéo ait eu quand même un gros
soulagement maintenant c'était aussi
flippant dans le sens où l'opération
pour retirer le lit podem c'est une
opération qui date de très peu de temps
en fait donc on est encore un peu des
cobayes pour la suite qu'est-ce qui a
été le plus pénible à vivre pour toi par
rapport à franchement le plus pénible je
pense que ça a été à l'adolescence parce
que c'est l'adolescence ton corps il
change complètement et je souffrais
énormément je me sentais vraiment forte
je me sentais grosse je me sentais way
difformes et puis le regard des hommes
parce que finalement c'était l'époque
des 2èmes snc d'octave et les webcams
donc à chaque fois battu voyais ma tête
en haut et quand je voyais les hommes en
vrai j'avais des réflexions mais sale
quoi en mode à bas l hemi quel duo met
alors en bas et je pouvais rien faire
donc ouais je pense que c'est plus au
moment de l'adolescence haute essayent
de plaire et finalement bas tous les os
en haut ça passait puis dès que j'allais
par exemple pour essayer des pantalons
mais c'est terrible et j'avais beau
faire des régime sur régime
et finalement bas je perdais pas du tout
donc voilà l'adolescence parce que je
pense passer la vingtaine tu finis par
pita que j'étais résigné franchement je
me suis dit bon bah c'est la vie
je serai comme ça et basta corps comment
est-ce que tu as l'impression d'avoir
réussi à apprendre à vivre avec
on sincèrement on n'apprend jamais à
vivre avec
c'est un complexe qui est constant
j'essayais de d'un peu de dissimuler
donc plutôt à prendre un mac billets
différemment ce qui était un petit peu
compliqué c'est que quand tu as donc
cette morphologie en fait objet de
tabliers un peu sexy tout le temps parce
que si tu veux six mois vu que le bas de
mes jambes étaient très forts et l'eau
était très fin si je m'étais quelque
chose d'un peu plus ample en eau
donc je n'étais pas prêt je me mettais
pas en avant mais en fait je ressemblais
à un cube
donc en fait c'était difficile parce que
j'avais toujours des commentaires où
elle s'habille de façon vulgaire et
c'est en fait non c'est juste que je
voulais pas faire une espèce de turin
une belle silhouette
donc voilà en fait tu apprends à vivre
avec ça après voilà c'est pas non plus
une maladie qui va être handicapante en
tout cas à mon stade en stade un peu
plus ça avance plus ça empire en stade
un an
c'est plus à prendre ingérer à un
complexe donc bah je me sentais bien
j'étais triste pour les bleus qui
apparaissait j'ai fini par me dire bon
bah ça apparaît ça repart j'avais pas de
solution donc voilà parents ce qu'il
faut savoir sur de cette maladie et
pourquoi aujourd'hui je veux vraiment
beaucoup en parler c'est que le problème
c'est que quand à la maladie l'udc s'est
pas connue même si sa touche une femme
sur dix c'est quand même un fléau campus
la maladie elle est reconnue par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ça
c'est quelque chose qui est très
important faut savoir que en stade 3 en
fait c'est que l'âme est déjà ckoi de
base c'est tout simplement que notre
grèce à nous elle est beaucoup plus
liquides qu'une grèce normal si j'ai
bien tout compris je pas médecin
et cette graisse en fait elle va appuyer
sur le système lymphatique et le système
veineux ce qui fait que ils vont se
comprimer et puisqu'on primes - ça passe
et si ça se comprime trop ce qui se
passe en fait en stade 3 eh bien ils
lâchent en fait le système lymphatique
et là tu passes en lin fodem et là en
fait ces terribles moi j'ai mon ancienne
voisine elle avait un hippodrome qui n'a
pas été détecté
elle n'a pas été soignée elle a enchaîné
les régimes parce que c'est ce que tu
veux faire en fait quand attentes et ce
qui s'est passé au final c'est qu'elle a
en fait ça a tout lâché aujourd'hui elle
peut même pu mettre 2
f elle chausse du 39 madame a dû 44,6 et
pris en charge à temps c'est ça tu y as
was a en fait en gros ce qui est triste
c'est qu'à pas vraiment de prise en
charge la paramètres des bas de
contention fernana tation manger
équilibré éviter les fast food il ya des
traitements chirurgicaux mais comme vous
connais mal la cause du l'hypoderme ne
sais pas s'ils sont temporaires ou
définitifs peut vraiment rien faire tu
es vraiment bloquer quoi donc maintenant
il ya en fait il ya aucun conseil qui
marche quoi on aurait dû me dire porte
un colon de contention et est encore
vraiment iliaque l'opération qui ne
change la forme de jambes mais en même
temps avec l'opération il ya beaucoup de
risques
tu peux te risqué d'arrivants
lymphoedème parce que leur technique si
tu veux on comprend pas trop comment ils
mangent pas le système lymphatique quoi
c'est vraiment flippant absolue tout
début le débat ça fait quoi ça fait
peut-être la technique de rôle donc la
technique que j'ai fait est les
premières opérations en 2003 donc seul
de loeb abbas a cédé enfants c est ce
que tu aurais envie de dire à des femmes
ou des jeunes femmes parce que c'est
vrai c'est ça qui sont touchés qu'est ce
que t'en as envie de leur dire si tu
pouvais t'adresser à la face caméra si
elle se pose des questions ou filiales
ils ont été diagnostiqués alors moi ce
que j'avais envie de vous dire c'est que
déjà un faux pas perdre espoir
deuxièmement il ya des hauts des
solutions sachez que le plus important
c'est surtout de ne pas faire un effet
yoyo parce que c'est ce qu'on a tendance
à faire on voit nos jambes on est
complexé ont fait que pleurer si je vous
dis c'est que je les fais je pense que
vous êtes peut-être dans ce cas on sent
vraiment désemparés et je trouve que
c'est horrible de sentir désemparés et
seul donc ce qu'il faut faire tout
simplement c'est commencer par réguler
votre alimentation
si vous avez une alimentation qui n'est
pas régulier ce qui a été mon cas moi je
tombais dans une autre maladie qui
s'appelle l'hyperphagie c'est à dire que
j'avais j'étais tellement triste que je
j'arrêtais de manger je perdais de poids
les gens ne bougeait pas en fait elle
restait vraiment conséquente est en fait
après j'étais tellement aînés
et que le régime ne servent à rien que
je je veux manger mais avec des
quantités énormes non la seule chose que
je puisse vous dire c'est que la
solution de l'opération c'est peut-être
pas forcément une solution parce que
attention et je le redis mais attention
aux chirurgiens français qui sont des
chirurgiens esthétiques
alors que là on parle d'une maladie donc
vraiment juste essayer de stabiliser
votre poids
achetez vous un collant de compression
rectiligne à my plate c'est un très long
mais c'est important fait sur mesure ça
sert à rien parce qu'en fait il ya ba
c'est pareil
depuis mon passage télé en fait
malheureusement tu vois un essor de
choses qui se développe 9
voilà un business moi ça me répugne et
ça ne sert à rien donc vraiment pour moi
ces alimentations c'est le collant et
marché au maximum garder espoir
je travaille pour converger des
solutions mais voilà il ya quelque chose
que tu veux rajouter à ce que le tueur a
un goût de la fin le mot de la fin
écoute je pense qu'il faut pas perdre
espoir faut toujours garder le sourire
c'est ce que je dis toujours en fait
faut garder le sourire parce que c'est
le sourire qui va t'amener vers des
choses positives
merci beaucoup et merci julien à bientôt
à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]